-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers.
And this is "Late Night,"
and it's Monday for all of us.
Let's get to the news.
Yesterday was the end
of the G7 summit,
and everyone has already
muted Biden on the text chain.
Today was former President
Trump's 75th birthday.
Well, it was gonna be,
but he said to stop the count.
[ As Donald Trump ]
I was 60 years old.
Then they start finding
all these extra birth--
71, 72.
Now I'm seventy--
Give me a break.
[ Normal voice ] President Biden
attended the NATO summit today
and met with the leaders o
Estonia, Latvia, and Lithuania
Said Biden, "I think I'm takin
all three of those."
After being fired from
"The New Yorker" magazine
last year for masturbating
on a Zoom call,
legal analyst Jeffrey Toobin
appeared on CNN last week.
But don't worry,
they were extra careful.
Former White House press
secretary Kayleigh McEnany
said yesterday she "never lied
while working for
former President Trump.
Added McEnany, "Or even when
I worked for President Obama."
A man dropping off a package
at a Florida post office
at 3:30 in the morning
recently discovered
a seven-foot alligator
walking around the lobby.
Still not as scary as a ma
dropping off a package
at the post office
at 3:30 in the morning.
"Uh, where do you send
hot meth?"
According to a recent survey
57% of Americans say --
have said, excuse me,
that they've wanted
to slap a politician,
thought I'm pretty sure
some politicians
have wanted to slap
57% of Americans.
Amazon announced yesterday
it's testing new technologie
to help make its warehouse
safer, including two roobot-
Roobots.
[ Laughter ]
Caught that one.
As soon as I said it, I wa
like, "It's not 'roobots.'
Including two robots
named Bert and Ernie.
And they brought in this guy
to make sure they meet
their quotas.